David Balkan company New York City is it a
knitting mill nor what they're winding here
is not yarn but fine copper wire coils the
Transformers essential to the manufacture
of sound equipment the coils are wound on
a stick as many as twenty at a time this
is one of the first steps in the making
of Public Address systems high fidelity
radios and the other electronic devices in
which the firm specializes when a stick of
Transformers has the necessary number of turns the
individual units can be cut apart with a bandsaw
a plant like this uses thousands of yards of
wire of all types and sizes here's a machine
that automatically cuts it to any desired
length and trims the insulation from each
end so it's all ready to be hooked up a
complex wiring layout is prefabricated
by workers who funnel coloured lines running
here and there between the nails the result
is a complex harness that leaves each wire
end at just the right spot to be connected
on the main assembly line the various
components are mounted in the chassis the
equipment looks like the most confusing
jumble imaginable but each worker knows
exactly where in the maze of wires to
make a connection or solder a joint
what they're making here is the amplifier for a
public address system of a kind very frequently
used in schools there's only one way to make
sure all the wires tubes and other electronic
parts will work and that's by testing them
on a setup designed and built right here in
the plant the amplifier then is added to
a console already fitted out with radio
receiver phonograph and other accessories
that allow it to be used for everything from
the broadcasting of music during lunch hour
to emergency announcements and fire drills
now with the unit all together there's a
performance test a microphone is plugged
in and the technician watches the
reaction on meters as he talks into it
the company with 25 years experience at making
Public Address systems for offices hospitals
and naval vessels now finds a wide new market in
the nation schools like this Elementary School
in Ridgewood New Jersey whose functions are
more effectively carried out when the principal
can pick up a mic and by throwing the right
switches make necessary announcements to one
classroom half a dozen or the entire school in
this as in so many of our newer schools modern
methods of Education have been extended
to include modern methods of communication
methods as up-to-date as those manifested
in the school buildings architecture